thank you for joining us here today i'm
christina swallow and i'm the director
of the nevada department of
transportation
with me here today are councilman
councilwoman diaz and councilman career
as well as captain spencer from las
vegas metro department metro police
department
we are here to talk today we are here to
talk today about our long-term effort to
address
the aging infrastructure safety and
operations
along the i-515 through downtown also
known as our downtown access project
this project will not be under
construction for at least five to seven
years
and should not be confused with the
interim repair project that we have that
will start construction in april
so this is the long-term fix to the
viaduct
the downtown access project is currently
in the environmental phase
and we are trying to determine the best
alternative of three
to meet the needs of the community of
ndot and of the city of las vegas
alternatives include removing the
viaduct
and recessing the freeway below grade or
rebuilding the freeway at a similar
height as today
but on fill for large portions of the
continuous viaduct structure
essentially removing the empty spaces
under the bridge on either side of the
three streets as you see here
where we're parked in all three
alternatives
we have eight surface streets that
currently travel
under i-515 that may be closed
permanently
these include 7th 8th
10th 14th 15th
16th 19th and 21st
two of these are proposed to be closed
to vehicles but will remain
as pedestrian crossings those are 15th
and 21st
in the recessed alternative only 4th
street is
also proposed for closure just south of
515.
in this scenario traffic would be routed
onto casino center or las vegas
boulevard to access the freeway
so you might be asking why is endot
proposing to close these streets
well from an engineering perspective
most of these streets
are not lengthy and they terminate just
north or south of the 515.
also closing them does not negatively
impact the rest of the system
or create lengthy detours however
we know that they will create detours
and it will
impact the community so we are actively
seeking
feedback from anyone who might be
impacted by these closures
we not in the city of las vegas have
spent a lot of time
talking about how to reach the community
that might be impacted by these closures
because we don't want to move forward
until we've heard from those who use
these roads and live in the area
we recently sent postcards i think if
you haven't seen them we recently sent
postcards
to more than 9 000 residents and
businesses in the area
team members have also been talking to
those businesses and first responders
and starting today we are implementing
test closures to solicit feedback
so starting today we are partially
closing the eight streets proposed for
closure and all three alternatives
as you can see here on 7th street with
the
cones and signage in place already
these partial closures will be in place
for three weeks
and include barricades across a portion
of the street with signage
to encourage the public to provide
feedback
about the project via a survey on our
website or by calling our community
feedback line
after the three week partial closures
we'll move into full closures for two
weeks
from march 29th to april 12th
[Music]
during that time frame march 29th to
april 12th
vehicles will have to use alternate
routes the goal
is for them to experience the closures
and provide feedback of that impact
during the partial and full closures the
sidewalk will remain
open for pedestrians but we still
encourage pedestrians and bicyclists
those that may be able to still traverse
the roads to reach out to us via our
website
or a community feedback line because the
full closures will impact them as well
and in fact
possibly impact them more with the
detours
we recognize that this may be
inconvenient
so it's so important to get the feedback
now when it's still temporary
we want to know how the community feels
about these closures and how they will
impact
the members that are impacted and their
families
once on the website the feedback will be
submitted via a survey tool that allows
the user to comment on as many of the
streets as they'd like
for instance if sometimes they use 14th
but sometimes they use 15 they can
comment on both
if participants call the community
feedback line a project representative
will ask them the same questions and
record their answers
and all communications are available in
spanish
and english i'd now like to invite
councilwoman diaz
and after her councilman career to the
podium to share their thoughts on this
community feedback effort
thank you christina and happy
international women's day
um you're a female engineer showing us
that
females can be trailblazers in all walks
of life
and i want to also congratulate every
single
one of you that has the mom and a sister
or
a significant other that celebrating
today it's about
making each other better i appreciate
and working with the city on this
project to get
everyone's input infrastructure projects
are important and they're so necessary
to make sure that we're keeping traffic
flowing
safely and efficiently
but we do understand that it doesn't
make it any less frustrating when you
have somewhere to go
and there are road closures this is why
we are doing these
test closures again there are test
closures
to gain feedback from all of you that
may be
impacted by this test closure
that's why it's so important that we get
your feedback that you
communicate with and what
is impacting or impeding your daily
um route so make sure that you
share the community's vision what does
this project
entail in the future are these tests
road
closures a smart thing or a not so smart
thing
it's also very important that we be
included that all voices are included in
this process and that we don't leave
anybody out and so
i want to highly encourage hispanics
latinos
to engage because everything has been
prepared in spanish
and there are um assistants waiting to
get your call
that can take your feedback and espanol
um i grew up in this community
um just a few blocks east and so this
is very near and dear to my heart to
make sure that we're learning
about uh and that we're hearing about
why it's important to replace this
infrastructure
but also how we can make it better and
more beautiful for you
once the team takes all of your input
and all of it is evaluated
then we'll go we're going to take what
you tell us and make the changes
either for or against something so it is
time to provide
your feedback i'm going to go ahead and
say a little bit of this in espanol
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and because the gods of the wind are
telling me that i need to hand over the
mic
to my colleague i'm going to go ahead
and introduce
someone who not only works beside me
because
our our words are adjacent each other
but
we really do believe in community and we
want to see what's best
for our community day in and day out i
introduce to you councilman
cedric creer
good afternoon everybody uh it's great
to be here happy international women's
day
as a father of two daughters a husband
for
27 years i really believe that uh a
woman's right
to excel and to be the best that the
world has to offer
is deep rooted in my uh in my heart
thank you councilwoman diaz thank you
director for having us here today
but i'm excited that the city and indot
are working together to make
infrastructure improvements to the core
of our community
i know it can be frustrating to see
orange cones on the road with no work
occurring
but these test closures will help the
team better understand how the community
feels about
these proposed street closures and
hopefully the data that is gathered
will limit future closures and make the
entire project
much more efficient all road and
infrastructure projects are inconvenient
but we hope to limit that inconvenience
while ensuring that the community's
roadways are maintained and that they
are safe
if you live in the area or use these
streets now is the time to speak up
and let ndot know how you want these
projects to be planned
the portion of us i 515 and 95 corridor
is a key
entryway into war three and the historic
west side
of ward five and we want to make sure
the community
is heard this is your time
don't wait until it's done to say i
didn't know about it
to sit back and not give input the time
is now and we want your input and we
value your input
so let us know how you feel about these
proposed closures
how they would impact you and your
family and i encourage you to visit the
website
or call the community feedback line to
share your thoughts
and don't forget that the survey will be
available through
april the 12th thank you and have a
fantastic day
thank you so much to councilwoman diaz
and councilman career for joining us
here today
we are really working and wanting to
make sure that we get this critical
feedback
we want to know how these closures will
impact you
and your family so please visit www
dot d
to take a brief survey or call our
community feedback line at
to speak 702-938-5440 a project
representative in english or spanish
once this outreach effort concludes ndot
and the city of las vegas will share
the results of this feedback and work
together to address the community's
responses
again thank you so much for coming out
with us today and
in advance for sharing your your
feedback thank you
um
so the viaduct is um the first
portion of the viaduct it's actually two
bridges and it is reaching or has
extended beyond its
useful useful service life now that
doesn't mean that it's dangerous by any
means it is safe and it you can continue
to drive it
one of the things we are doing as you
heard me mention earlier is we have an
interim project that's going to start in
april and that's going to address any
concerns that we have to extend the
useful life of the viaduct
that said if you drive the viaduct you
know that it is
it is a choke point in our valley it
slows down we have congestion issues we
have crashes
and so we want to make sure that it can
that this corridor can continue to serve
our growing and vibrant community
and so we have to we have to look at how
do we replace it to make sure that we
can move the vehicles and the freight
the people in the freight through it
but also do it in a safe way
yeah so like i said we're still in our
environmental process so we're
working through the ndep process and
i'm sorry the environmental process and
we are looking at adding capacity to it
we're also looking at continuing
to provide some additional hov access uh
for instance specifically at maryland
parkway so we'll be providing additional
access to the community
there is also a currently in
consideration and additional access at
city parkway
so in addition to the improvements that
will do to the corridor itself we're
also providing additional access
to the local community via those new
interchanges
you know uh we could replace the viaduct
with a viaduct however if you it's a
very expensive proposition to do that um
and then you have a lot of empty vacant
space that becomes a maintenance concern
for the for the city and for endot
and so we're looking at how can we most
economically achieve the aims of the
transportation project
but also serve our community and really
provide a
a better option for the community
you know no matter what we do the
viaduct addressing the viaduct concerns
is going to be a significant project
either replacing it or putting it in a
recessed option
either one is going to be a significant
project
[Music]
yes it is yes it is this is currently
the longest bridge in the state of
nevada the second largest longest
just opened last fall and the centennial
bowl so if with if and when we replace
the viaduct unless we do it as a viaduct
it the longest bridge in the state will
be at the centennial wall
[Music]
i think i heard you the wind and the
speakers is interfering but
you're right it is called the downtown
access project and we are concerned
about how
the viaduct limits access today and how
we may in uh
developing the project how we may work
to improve that or
further limit it so we're working to try
that's why we want this community
feedback
is to really understand how we can make
the project better work for those that
are
on the ground in the vicinity of the
project not just those that are
traveling through
oh this is why though i don't have those
exact the exact age off the top of my
head
60.
the the first bridges the second bridge
is not that old
so there's two alternate routes
[Music]
today
the detour routes um
so if you go to the website that'll um
that'll show you but also so if we close
seventh and eighth ninth is going to
stay open um
10th will be partially closed but if you
wanted to detour from 10th you can
either take 9th or maryland parkway
14th um will be
temporarily closed but maryland is the
detour uh
16th bruce is the detour so there are
detours throughout we're trying to
minimize
if we do close permanently any of these
corridors that the
detour would be minimal and we're being
very cognizant of the impact on on the
pedestrians and cyclists these all of
these corridors have
a good number of pedestrians and
cyclists that use them in any detour can
be detrimental when you're
powering yourself so we're wanting to
make sure we hear the feedback from
those that's why even though the
sidewalks will remain open we're still
hoping those community members will
reach out and let us know how
how it could impact them
yeah so just yeah please make sure you
go to the website and again that's down
that's www.n.d.a.p.com
and the phone number is 702-938-5440 it
may factor into it so we're also at
concurrent to this project in the
and the nepa process that we're working
on with this project we're also doing
the next uh
phase of nepa for i-11 to figure out how
i-11 will traverse our city our valley
and we are looking there are three
corridors we actually just had a virtual
public meeting on this last fall on i-11
and as that continues we're hoping to
have that identified close to the same
time that corridor identified close to
the same time we finished the nepa
on the downtown access project so that
if it does um become the perform if 95
becomes the preferred corridor we can
plan
and design for that
potentially potentially
all right thank you again everyone i
really appreciate you spending the time
and and helping us get the word out so
that we can
we can hear from the community we
definitely want to make sure their
voices are included